from a jury in his fourth fourth year  with Dallas's steadily improved first  tunisian born player the NBA as teams a  retic connects on a fitter signed a  couple of players who have been injured  and including Wilson Chandler Redick a  3d transit video game Dennis Smith and  Anton church have been playing together  there's a point play opportunity coming  up through JJ Redick pondering what to  do here give it a retic let him shoot a  three he's still perfect look at the  feet by Koch is gonna reject him by  muscala  Rennick a three Eddie knocks you down JJ  reddick stay attached to him he is yet  to miss the shot  [Applause]  but Carlos did not not a critic stop  perfect JJ reddick ten for ten